this program is brought to you by Emory
University I was a big comic book fan
growing up and what really interests me
as I watch these stories move from the
comic books to the screen 3040 years
after the origin original comic books
were written is the change in the way in
which we think about and portray the
technologies involved so Spiderman
originally was bitten by a spider that
had been exposed to radiation the
Fantastic Four
became the Fantastic Four because they
were astronauts who had gone into space
and gone through a strange radiation
belt in space and came back with these
powers and that's because at the time in
the 60s and 70s in the in the midst of
of you know the still the response to
nuclear blasts the development of
nuclear energy and an enormous amount of
social protests around the use of around
nuclear energy and radiation a certainty
that we were all going to be destroyed
by a nuclear blast and the resultant
radiation that would radiation was the
scientific phenomenon around which
people had fear and mystery it's not
true anymore
that isn't how we think about radiation
anymore now it's how we think about
genetics so when the first spider-man
movie came out the spider that bit Peter
Parker was not subject to radiation as
it was in the comic books it had been
genetically manipulated and if a new
spider-man comes out 20 years from now
maybe the spider will be a product of
synthetic biology who knows what the
technology will be twenty years from now
that we'll have that same sense of
mystery and fear so it's fascinating to
watch as we move forward in time the
science has to keep up in the sense that
if you use outdated science it's just
people just don't believe it because
they know too much about it so you have
to find what is that technology right
now that holds that sense of potential
the sense of
people know something about it so it's
not completely mysterious to them but
they don't know enough about it to know
that that particular use of it could
never happen or is absurd and so
genetics is we're in that genetic moment
now and that will pass and there'll be
something else in the future but that's
one of the reasons why I think the x-men
are so interesting why because they're
genetic mutants why spider-man
transformed from a radiation phenomenon
to a genetic phenomenon and so the
movies just have to follow that kind of
social trending in order to really be
able to resonate with their audiences
you
the preceding program is
University